this guy's literally trying to start an
ad pocalypse because someone was mean to
him now we are all going to lose money
just because he doesn't like you get in
line
I'm really glad to have our next guest
you can file them on the twitter at tim
cast he's a journalist youtuber podcast
or his YouTube is youtube.com slash tim
cast and also as tim cat / tim cast News
senior Tim mr. Tim Poole how are you sir
thanks for being here pretty good yeah
thanks for having me appreciate it thank
you and I appreciate that Tim Poole
level of enthusiasm as to how well
you're pretty good I'm okay yeah yeah
yeah rather I've been called a
milquetoast offense sitter okay I guess
III think milquetoast fence-sitter is
redundant I don't really know that you
you need to repeat that I don't think
your milquetoast friend fence-sitter I
just think you're very you're very
mellow this obviously um has been going
on this week a campaign initiated by by
NBC Vox the Carlos and maza I don't know
what just the guy who does the videos at
Vox an active effort to get our channel
D platformed even tweeting that people
should go masked flag our videos let me
ask you you've talked about sort of with
Twitter remember on Joe Rogan's show and
it was great I highly recommend people
go check out that show yeah
you've talked about this when we
appreciate this the support that you've
you've given this channel in regards to
this controversy how common is this sort
of flagging banning campaign or or
really what would you say is if people
need to understand the dynamics of
what's going on right now because it's
easy to feel like you're drinking from a
firehose when it comes to sort of
corporate censorship silencing what
would you really want to drill into
people there's a very very simple fact
you can tell people to prove 100 percent
the social media platforms are biased
against conservatives and it's their
misgendering policy progressives are a
very progressive zhh don't represent the
entirety of the left according to the
hidden tribes report by a group I
believe it's called a group called more
in common progressive activists in the
US are 8% of the country it's these
people primarily who view the
misgendering thing the way Twitter does
that if someone decides to have a
preferred pronoun you have to use it
otherwise you can be bent conservatives
tend to disagree you know the majority I
would say I mean ben shapiro is much
much opposed to way more than just the
idea of misgendering but you know in
terms of the trans debate women and
trans women competing in sports
you once got a headlock by an angry
transgender for doing you yeah well then
on that show where they dr. Drew was Zoe
Zoe tor who threatened us put him in
home in an ambulance yet horrible
horrible experience it plays no role in
political discourse but wildly
entertaining yeah so though just look at
the rules and and I told this to Jack
Dorsey full stop you are biased against
conservatives and he didn't understand
this I said listen if a conservative
doesn't believe you're you know in
misgendering the way you do you have an
ideological difference where you're
enforcing rules based on your personal
ideology he went on to say well we have
studies we've read that show the suicide
rate is higher therefore we're trying to
protect them and I asked what about you
know general body dysmorphia are you
know and what point do you draw a line
and say this group should or shouldn't
be protected right you know can you not
make fun of depression because people
who are depressed have the highest rate
of suicide that's literally let you know
particularly it's actually it's not
higher than transgenders that's actually
something that's not no it's not it's
actually not there's no other
demographic that I know to be as high
outside of from what I understand like
paranoid schizophrenics even been she
appears made this point American slaves
didn't have nearly as high of an
attempted suicide rate if I'm not
mistaken it's about forty one forty two
percent for your both pre and post-op by
the way so this idea that it's
societally sort of based oppression
it just doesn't bear out but yeah it's
actually a higher rate than those who
would be considered like even
manic-depressive I would say that's the
easiest thing you can say right it's not
a debate you point that out in people
gonna go oh I guess you're right now the
people on the Left the progressives say
so what you're saying is that
conservatives are mad they can't
misgender people and it's like we'll
hold on they view misgendered in an
inverse way they believe that if someone
is biologically male and you say she you
have misgendered them right so it's
literally just you I don't know how you
rectify that there's two different
ideologies here and only one it's only
enforced in one direction yeah right
right yeah that is a great that is a
great point also this idea of I think
you see it's sort of to get back this
NBC Vox thing let me ask you this have
you ever seen people on the right or
people like I know that I've never done
this but how common is it see people on
the right to encourage mass flagging and
removals of points of view they disagree
with I'm not familiar with it happens
but it's extremely extremely rare right
and so you know this is another thing
that puts me kind of more on your side
in an issue like this I get people
tweeting at me saying oh here comes Tim
to defend the conservative I'm like well
steven crowder isn't calling for someone
have their career
destroyed simply because they said
something mean on the internet right you
know in fact you've actually told people
not to Doc's not to harass so it's kind
of like you can't have Carl's Mazda
advocating for throwing milkshakes at
people to humiliate them and then
complaining about someone saying mean
words that humiliates them right I mean
we're yeah
one is an app by the way throwing a
milkshake at someone is actually assault
yeah that easily it is it is legally
assault yeah actually you're right it's
further than assault it's actually
battery and people who say well
milkshakes haven't really heard you
actually that's not true people can put
anything in a milkshake first off people
can hide something heavy in there and
whip it at you people can put acid in
there and I've always said I've always
condemned dachshund because I was docks
at one point I am actually on the ISIS
kill list it's not people saying mean
things I've been in communication with
the FBI not only that there's so many
people in the FBI kill list when I spoke
with people yeah they're like almost
everyone makes that list like but there
is an ultra premium list sort of the
elite fliers club like in your at the
top of that VIP so here's our number
i've always actively discouraged it i
never want any physical violence in them
that was another thing Jack Dorsey's but
with you about physical safety whether
it's daxing whether it's milk shaking
but this idea that mass flagging and
reporting something to get it removed
Brian I got yeah I got one better for
you okay one of one of the there's a
body of journalistic ethics from this
Society for Professional Journalists if
you go to J school you probably know
this but apparently these people who
work at Vox don't it's called minimize
harm mmm-hmm
when you when you when you seek to do a
story if if revealing information about
your subject would cause them harm you
do your best to avoid that which means
if I heard that a group of people who
are very very awful and dangerous were
using a certain company I would reach it
at the company without naming them
because it's not my position as a
journalist to cause harm to them or
anyone more importantly to interfere in
the story and make the story you know
change the story as a result of my
actions when a journalist goes down to
cover something on the ground you should
not be putting your body in the way to
change what happens you're trying to
tell people what happens that caused the
reaction right however what happens now
is I'd actually have evidence of this I
received some leaked documents we'll see
what I if I can do anything with it
journalists use very fanciful
language targeting businesses and
companies to cause maximum harm to
specific individuals so they're not
seeking to when they report on say the
proud boys they're not seeking to inform
the audience as to what's going on
they're seeking to inflict damage on the
business and the proud boys what they'll
do is they'll say something like this
let's say you're a laundromat they see a
proud boy go inside the laundromat they
wait till a person leaves they'll go
inside go to the manager and say the
proud boys are white supremacists why do
you support white supremacists and then
the manager goes what are you talking
about of course I don't well of course
you do
and so they'll send a message to a
company saying why do you support X
mm-hmm instead of asking if they do they
assume it is true and then man I have
seen these hit pieces go flying but the
best part is they don't so I'll give you
an example CNN for instance reached out
to Facebook about a group called mafic
media Mavic media is anti-war left-wing
content aimed at Millennials and there I
believe 51% owned by roughly which is
funded by Russia Today CNN reaches out
to Facebook and says why are you
supporting big ladies who do the
BuzzFeed boldly yeah sorry apology math
ik is very much like no intervention in
Syria things like that you know so ah
but they CNN reached out to Facebook and
I don't know exactly what they asked but
I in my personal opinion I imagine it
was something like why is Facebook
supporting Russian propaganda because
what ends up happening is Facebook then
suspended the media company who broke no
rules and it wasn't until after the
suspension does CNN publish the story
mafic media suspended by Facebook
because they're owned by Russia blah
blah blah that's not what journalism is
supposed to be doing so you actually
have left-wing activists who have gotten
jobs because it's lucrative for the
companies and they're not trying to
learn they're trying to impact right
that's that's you look at Jim Acosta
he's straight up says he grandstands
that's the point right now so their
trial he says that now and that's the
thing for the longest time he tried to
fame that he was objective and I've
always said this idea that there's this
death of objective journalism if you go
back to Walt Walter Cronkite and
actually read what he's written and see
what his quote story said I don't think
he can be a journalist and not be a
liberal for a long time we thought he
was my god an actual journalist people
are inherently biased I don't believe in
any golden era of unbiased journalism I
just think that now it's more clear and
to me that's somewhat a good thing
because at least we know where the lines
are drawn I wish it weren't so polarized
but it is and that's a very interesting
point that you bring up there there's
also been a real transition because you
talked about it being financially viable
with Vox and this Carlos Maz aware now
they've shifted from myself Vox to the
targeting of advertisers on YouTube and
a lot of other youtubers people who
would not support me at all politically
are pretty upset by this I think that's
where they may have screwed the pooch
have you been following this and is this
kind of a common tactic yeah yes so the
the video I have earlier today it kind
of talks about how Carlos masa in his
interview with M 2 a.m. 2 DM I think
it's called on BuzzFeed he said he gets
the point where he talks about how you
know you're harassing all stuff but then
says you know it's not you it's that
YouTube is distracting the advertisers
from the fact that they can't control
their platform and their advertisements
appear on you know hateful bigoted
homophobic content etc etc and I saw a
tweet from keemstar who does dramaalert
on YouTube it's like YouTube culture
stuff and he said this guy's literally
trying to start an ad pocalypse because
someone was mean to him now we are all
going to lose money just because he
doesn't like you know so this might get
in line yeah look the whole digital
media's been hurting right vice
literally right now he's pulled up a
story vice just fired two of its
longtime editors someone whose mode the
company for 10 years they've had layoffs
CNN just laid off their London staff CNN
just put their Friel and their
contractors on a net 90 that means if
you work for them they won't pay you for
three months that's flying and seeing
your staff that's crazy right so a lot
of these companies are hurting all of a
sudden very conveniently you know a
story came out from Vox
not a couple weeks ago where they
acknowledge their evaluation is probably
down from their initial of investment we
just saw a story where Vox is now
switching to freelancers and part-timers
which to many is indicative of them
hurting we don't I don't wanna Q's box
of failing rates like that but then all
of a sudden Karl's Mazda comes out
you've criticized him before but it's
now it's now that and then he advances
his argument to talk about advertisers
instead of you and he's losing his
identity the target
the platform as a whole accusing it of
being an outright Haven I find it I find
it fascinating that he's playing the
victim here that he is this little guy
being oppressed when he actually is one
of the most prominent figures on a
channel with with you know what's us or
you keep in mind - this is also one
thing you talk like we have you know
close to four million they have close to
six million but the very first Vox
rebuttal that we've done which by the
way include on average I think about 8
to 12 times the sources that are
publicly listed that Fox never does
then they then then they do we might
have had less than half a million
subscribers so it's not like we were
punching down we were going after the
biggest channel because we're gonna hold
on a second they support the Australian
gun buyback we're going to rebut that
and again hours and hours of content
people need to know tossed in a side of
lispy gay Latino for Vox if people want
to watch the videos in their entirety
listen we can have the conversation that
conservatives shouldn't be allowed to do
comedy I didn't call him a holster I
didn't call him a feckless I think it
was positively tame that's just my
opinion but it's not there there's no
doubt that there's a substantial
rebuttal to the arguments made over
there at Vox and by the way we've done
it with Vox when it wasn't this guy we
did it when it was that Ezra Klein guy
and vice it's about 1% of our content so
that's what bothers me is is the
dishonesty in people taking something
it's been going on for a long time when
we were a channel it was very small and
actually really punching back at the
bully right so so easily I kind of see
it when it comes to political discourse
I discourage mockery name-calling
whatever however I recognize you're a
comedian you're not a journalist you
know when Tucker Carlson called brian
Stelter a eunuch i pushed back on that
in several videos like i do not think
that's appropriate and your instance
you're right
you know feckless cops pollster and
things like that have been done we've
seen way more egregious stuff on the
left but it's not about a tit for tat
it's kind of Jon Stewart's Trevor Noah
John Oliver they routinely mock and and
and target people at or above their
level and Carlos maza gets a million
views per video he's not some random
nobodies small guy being punched down
you're a guy who's mocking him and doing
a comedy bit if he was if he was a
private citizen that and you know any
posted a video of Nancy Pelosi I'd have
some criticism for you but he's not
right yeah varies
I would I would argue he's extremely
powerful with nearly with
100,000 subscribers a million views per
video having access to 6 million subs in
a company that's funded to the tune of
200 million dollars by NBC it's my
understanding yeah that's just that's
just the NBC Universal investment yeah
it doesn't include any other investors
which is why I wonder like how did you
lose all this money where did it go I
mean 200 million what how what do you
how many strike throughs are you guys
doing we only see what every two weeks
it is it is really remarkable but yeah I
think I'm also people hopefully no you
know when we do a change my mind or even
if you look at the leftists we've had in
the show we've had conversations with or
debate and it's gotten heated from Naomi
Wolf to Sally Kohn to Christopher Titus
to the guy from Think Progress the guy
from slate or salon
I've never insulted them there's a
difference when I'm doing a bit and
you're talking with someone and I've
always tried to delineate because I
listen I really the last thing I would
ever want is to pick on someone and be
rude to them in person when they've
given that you know done me the courtesy
of appearing on the program I feel like
I've made I've made several videos so my
second channel which is the Tim cast
news one where I regularly talk about
fairness and rights I made a video
recently you have no rights the world is
cruel and unfair and I talked about the
woman who I you who fell 20 feet broke
her leg and had to drag herself to the
stream and eat moths and drink dirty
water to survive I'd like to I'd like to
ask many of the progressives where was
her right to health care is there is
there is there anyone is she certainly
had a right to speech defense freedom of
movement etc so probably why I'm not you
know overtly liberal or progressive is
because I'm not 100% on board with Sang
health care is a human right mm-hmm
then the other story was the Mount
Everest where you had all this crowding
and I and I asked when in one of the
stories they said people were collapsing
because they ran out of oxygen do you
think any of those people said here take
mine of course not because when it came
down to the harshness the harsh
realities of the world people had to
secure their own face mask before
securing the mask of the people next to
them so I see someone like Carlos Massa
who calls for physical attacks on people
it's a milk shake I think it's really
low level but still you're tell--you're
saying make physical contact with
another person in violation of their
autonomy that's that's an egregious
violation but then he gets mad that
someone's that mean words Tim and so
here's where I end up do I do I think we
get anywhere with mockery and an insult
of course not I think it's detrimental
however people call me things all day
every day
and I'm an adult I not really bothered
you can call me literally wherever you
want
I opened the segment by saying I'm a
milquetoast fence sitter and I think
it's funny
and I would actually like to get one
extended here but so let me before we go
to the web extended let's go back to
this kind of trend of big journalism big
tech on a national let me ask you this
do you think that this trend is going to
reverse do you think there's hope for
people who are sort of free speech
advocates on places like YouTube and
social media or do you just see these
places kind of eating themselves alive i
I kind of go back and forth on this when
it's tough I will say with the with the
EF F coming out now saying we have to
deal with this that's that's really good
news I also think regulation is coming
and regulation can only ratchet in one
direction as it pertains to free speech
I don't know if wider regulation of
Facebook Google Twitter etc would result
in something positive what I do know is
as far as it goes with free speech any
regular regulation implement in terms of
speech will guarantee you the right
speech so we've already seen the Supreme
Court Rule that these these digital
spaces the government cannot restrict
your access to them now we've seen it
with that Trump lawsuit public officials
can't block you and this is now now you
know biding Oakland has to be blocked
right now yeah she can't that's illegal
you can file a suit you can the night
the night First Amendment Foundation I'm
not sure at night foundations journalism
they're they're based out of Columbia
Journalism school they they tweeted to
Ocasio Cortes she was running afoul of
the First Amendment they deleted the
tweet because you know these people
rarely like to police their own but
right ah they did it well actually I did
that back they sometimes eat their own
too much I think that's really good news
I think I think regulation look here's
another point where I'm probably to the
left of you i'm i think regulation will
absolutely be a good thing in this
regard and in many other guards so no i
don't think i don't think so i've talked
about this in my position has been
pretty clear i think the first step
before we get to sweeping legislative
overhaul and this is what i've been
advocating for a long time the first
step is to get them basically in a court
of law
and to declare whether they are
publishers or platforms put them in the
hot seat and if they say we are
platforms then we say okay we're gonna
regulate you're such but if they say
they're publishers we say okay but then
you have to be honest about your
business practice i think it's an easier
first step
but it's actually the platformers
publisher has to do with whether with
whether or not they can be sued for
libel and the the reason they're able to
ban in what they want is actually a
First Amendment issue and that's that's
where it's complicated because Twitter
is arguing everything on our platform is
our speech and you can't make us speak
right and they're right so if the
government rules Twitter has a massive
impact on the political space the new
space in our government there for free
speech for the individual must be
protected then Twitter opens the doors
and lost people back on the platform I
don't necessarily know if it's the right
thing to do I lean towards that
direction but I also recognize you will
end up seeing ridiculous trolling going
crazy at the same time you have the
ability to block and by all means use it
liberally you know yeah so what but I
still think again that would that would
at least open the doors to know what the
policies are and like you said if they
wanted to Claire there they are
publishers they should be held liable in
other words and if right now you are
policing speech if right now you're
saying this point of view is allowed but
calling a biological male he is not it's
a banna Belov ence well if you are now a
publisher it does have to be conferring
with the law and that okay you can be
held legally responsible for that speech
on your publishing platform now if you
want to say you're basically a platform
what people often sort of refer to as
social utilities public utilities which
is they've enjoyed some of those
protections that's why you can't
necessarily sue them right now they do
have to pick a lane and before we say
we're gonna legislate them as either a
publisher a platform I think having them
answer would be a good first less
expensive less invasive step and I think
they'd have to start straightening up
and fly right okay let me before we go
to the web exhibit here okay go ahead
you about say something I was going to
say the bigger problem is cultural there
are our business our private
institutions are extremely susceptible
and weak to low grade activism thirty
people on Twitter complaining to a brand
and that brand losses you know goes goes
apeshit and shuts everything down and
our businesses need to become more
resilient to a bunch of you know people
on Twitter yeah well that also brings me
to this last point we can touch on it
and then we'll continue the web extended
you know you've talked about this sort
of trend too of targeting when people
talk about bullying big news media big
corporate could these corporate
conglomerates targeting individuals at a
national level
so what the Covington kids like you
mention I think how much did you mention
Daily Beast and the guy who nominated
Pelosi video on CNN just recently this
is something it does seem like that
there's been an acceleration recently
where they don't seem to mind at all
daxing individual people or violation of
privacy rights yeah that's called
maximizing harm it's the complete
opposite of ethical journalism you know
even the Yasha ELISA is a great
journalist and he I love when he calls
them out for this he said publishing
this guy's name did nothing for the
story absolutely nothing they published
his photograph they made they published
his criminal history none of that none
of that is relevant they could have
talked about how they found the guy and
he comes from you know working-class
means that's interesting but why why
should you ruin this guy's life it's
because it's punishment it's it's a
threat these are his activism it's
maximizing the harm against a private
individual who has no chance of fighting
against a massive multi-billion dollar
corporation right yeah I think that's a
good point I think the sort of I guess
equalizing factor there for example with
us and Vox is yeah they are this massive
corporation with hundreds of millions of
dollars we started out of our you know
started out of my den but having that
platform and having a voice is equally
or comparably as valuable and that's why
they want to silence the voice it's
leveled the playing field a little bit
all right we're gonna go to what extent
that is though youtube.com slash Tim
Poole is it not tim tooten cast and Tim
cast news and you were on Twitter at Tim
cast tin pool thank you so much hey if
you like this video this is the part
where I would usually tell you to
subscribe but I can't do it anymore I'm
gonna tell you to subscribe and then
YouTube is going to decide that we can't
reach you even though you subscribe to
this channel and then I'll say hit the
notification bell and then the
notification bell won't even be there
anymore I don't know what to say more
than likely you'll find my face in a
milk carton but do what you can to stop
it it's just that it's just it probably
won't do much